dans des organes de presse répandent des
contrevérités infamante
ce ne sont plus des journalistes ce sont
des organes d'un flux ans rhj est tous
des scouts nick ont été des organes
l'influencent durant cette campagne qui
ont à plusieurs reprises produit des
contre-vérités sur ma personne et ma
campagne
c'était à versailles il y a un an
emmanuel macron régler ouvertement ses
comptes avec deux médias qui l'accusé
d'avoir relayé défèque news pendant la
campagne présidentielle un an plus tard
une proposition de loi contre les
fausses nouvelles arrivent au parlement
[Musique]
bienvenue chez arte france
financé à 100% par le kremlin avec
contient la chaîne défend le point de
vue de la russie sur l'actualité mais
récuse les accusations de fait news
depuis son lancement en décembre dernier
rt est étroitement surveillée par le csa
qui verrait ses pouvoirs étendus par la
nouvelle loi
demain le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel pourrait même suspendre le
conventionnement de la chaîne
c'est ça être une autorité
administrative ce n'est pas une autorité
indépendante donc déjà c'est un premier
problème de confier ça à une autorité
qui dépend finalement de l'état et puis
pour le reste une loi qui serait faite
sur mesure pour rt ce serait une loi
entre guillemets quasi à 2000m et ça ce
serait pas constitutionnel donc on
vérifiera si le droit est bel et bien
respecté mais on peut pas faire une loi
contre une chaîne ou alors c'est
simplement qu'on veut un petit peu
contrôler l'information et ça ce serait
dommage c'est sans doute pour ça que le
syndicat national des journalistes parle
de censure et toute la profession
dénonce plus globalement une loi qui
porte en elle des dérives de contrôle de
l'information
sous le feu des critiques la procédure
d'urgence pour stopper la diffusion
d'une fausse information
en période électorale un juge aurait
alors 48 heures pour déterminer si une
information est fausse
le texte exige aussi plus de
transparence de la part des plateformes
numériques
selon reporters sans frontières si
l'intention est bonne elle comporte
néanmoins un risque
ça n'est ni les états ni les plates
formes qui sont légitimes et dans les
deux classes il le faisait ce serait
dangereux à distinguer le bon grain de
l'ivraie à dire ce qui relève du
journalisme honnête de ce qui relève de
la rumeur ou de l'information
malveillantes
pour rsf c'est donc aux journalistes
même de valoriser les bonnes pratiques
mais pour un collège d'experts
missionnés par la commission européenne
cela doit s'accompagner d'une éducation
aux médias à l'ère des trolls alors moi
évidemment je pousse l'air dr les elfes
un salaire que ce que je dis c'est il
faut mobiliser la population il faut lui
montrer lui expliquer justement les
différentes formes de féminin c'est un
processus éducatif l'éducation aux
médias c'est une forme d'autorégulation
c'est sans doute le meilleur film alors
même exercice que tout à l'heure vous
avez juste m'expliquer voilà vous avez
compris ce que vous voyez qu'il
chacun leur avis mais c'est pas qui a
raison et qui a tort
très bonne question qu'est ce que ça
change que ce monsieur soit payer 150
millions euros par total qui soit pas du
pipeau débarquera pas être objectif
d'accor laisser éduquer plutôt que
légiférer fait dans ce collège de vichy
24 élèves de 4e développent leur esprit
critique
si vous êtes une génération en fait vous
allez avoir une information et cette
information vous la gardez pas pour vous
vous avez à transmettre et c'est
important tout le temps que vous la
vérifier quand on discute avec les
élèves et compare les réseaux sociaux
tout de suite après ils vous disent ben
voila moi je regarde le journal télévisé
mais j'ai rien à en dire sauf que le
journal télévisé aussi la formation se
fabrique
lorsque vous avez des journaux télévisés
qui accumule par exemple au moment des
grèves six ou sept sujets sur le
mécontentement des usagers
bon bah ça c'est un choix éditorial
c'est une hiérarchie de l'information et
ça produit une certaine forme
d'information c'est important aussi
d'avoir une certaine distance critique
en jeu recréer de la confiance entre
producteurs et consommateurs de
l'information
d'après le baromètre annuel du journal
la croix sur la confiance dans les
médias
deux français sur trois doutent de
l'indépendance et journalistes
[Musique]